have just chaired a meeting of the
cabinet where we agreed that the
government should call a general
election to be held on the 8th of June I
want to explain the reasons for that
decision what will happen next
and the choice facing the British people
when you come to vote in this election
last summer after the country voted to
leave the European Union Britain needed
certainty stability and strong
leadership and since I became Prime
Minister
the government has delivered precisely
that despite predictions of immediate
financial and economic danger since the
referendum we have seen consumer
confidence remain high record numbers of
jobs and economic growth that has
exceeded all expectations we have also
delivered on the mandate that we were
handed by the referendum result Britain
is leaving the European Union and there
can be no turning back and as we look to
the future the government has the right
plan for negotiating our new
relationship with Europe we want a deep
and special partnership between a strong
and successful European Union and a
United Kingdom that is free to chart its
own way in the world that means we will
regain control of our own money our own
laws and our own borders and we will be
free to strike trade deals with old
friends and new partners all around the
world this is the right approach and it
is in the national interest but the
other political parties oppose it at
this moment of enormous national
significance there should be unity here
in Westminster but instead there is
division the country is coming together
but Westminster is not
in recent weeks labor have threatened to
vote against the final agreement we
reach with the European Union the
Liberal Democrats have said they want to
grind the business of government to a
standstill the Scottish National Party
say they will vote against the
legislation that formally repeals
Britain's membership of the European
Union and unelected members of the House
of Lords have vowed to fight us every
step of the way
our opponents believe because the
government's majority is so small that
our resolve will weaken and that they
can force us to change course they are
wrong they underestimate our
determination to get the job done and I
am not prepared to let them endanger the
security of millions of working people
across the country because what they are
doing jeopardizes the work we must do to
prepare for brexit at home and it
weakens the government's negotiating
position in Europe if we do not hold a
general election now their political
game playing will continue and the
negotiations with the European Union
will reach their most difficult stage in
the run-up to the next scheduled
election division in Westminster will
risk our ability to make a success of
brexit and it will cause damaging
uncertainty and instability to the
country so we need a general election
and we need one now because we have at
this moment a one-off chance to get this
done while the European Union agrees
it's negotiating position and before the
detailed talks begin I have only
recently and reluctantly come to this
conclusion since I became Prime Minister
I have said that there should be no
election until 2020 but now I have
concluded that the only way to guarantee
certainty and stability for the years
ahead
is to hold this election and seek your
support for the decisions I must take
and so tomorrow I will move a motion in
the House of Commons calling for a
general election to be held on the 8th
of June that motion are set out by the
fixed term Parliament act will require a
two-thirds majority of the House of
Commons so I have a simple challenge to
the opposition parties you have
criticised the government's vision for
brexit you have challenged our
objectives you have threatened to block
the legislation we put before Parliament
this is your moment to show you mean it
to show you are not opposing the
government for the sake of it to show
that you do not treat politics as a game
let us tomorrow vote for an election let
us put forward our plans for brexit and
our alternative programs for government
and then let the people decide and the
decision facing the country will be all
about leadership it will be a choice
between strong and stable leadership in
the national interest with me as your
prime minister or weak and unstable
coalition government led by Jeremy
Corbyn propped up by the Liberal
Democrats who want to reopen the
divisions of the referendum and Nicola
Sturgeon and the SNP every vote for the
Conservatives will make it harder for
opposition politicians who want to stop
me from getting the job done every vote
for the Conservatives will make me
stronger when I negotiate for Britain
with the prime ministers presidents and
chancellors of the European Union every
vote for the Conservatives will mean we
can stick to our plan for a stronger
Britain and take the right long term
decisions for a more secure future it
was with reluctance that I decided the
country needs this election but it is
with strong conviction that I say it is
necessary to secure the strong and
stable leadership the country needs to
see us through brexit
beyond so tomorrow let the House of
Commons vote for an election let
everybody put forward their proposals
for brexit and their programs for
government and let us remove the risk of
uncertainty and instability and continue
to give the country the strong and
stable leadership it demands